this week
on brian ross investigates a family
tragedy playing out in court this week
father versus son over the murder of the
mother
not guilty iowa farmer jason carter
was found not guilty of the murder of
his mother shirley carter
but his father bill carter sued him in
civil court
and won a 10 million verdict against his
son
for the death of the mother and then i
knew
that he did now this week the iowa
supreme court is being asked
to overturn the civil perfect or give
jason carter
a new civil trial based on new evidence
do you really want a chance for another
trial absolutely
i'm all for it let's go back and really
show people how things
were plus an exclusive inside look at
some of the organizers
of the january stop the steel booth
including
this republican party operative this
begins the rebellion
everyone at this point comes prepared
for battle to protest it's no longer
just these peaceful marches that we have
it is it is it is battle greg palace let
me ask you the same question do you
anticipate
more trouble more violence in the coming
months
yeah absolutely from the law and crime
trial network this is brian ross
investigates
good evening and thank you for joining
us and welcome to our viewers on
facebook live
i'm brian ross joined as always by my
colleague rhonda schwartz
and rhonda we begin with an exclusive
inside look at one of the organizers
behind the january 6
stopped the steel rally and the capital
steps that led to riot and insurrection
he's one of the more unlikely people
helping to stir things up
a young african-american man who claims
to have deep ties to both
the far right and some republicans in
congress rhonda
that's right brian his name is ali
alexander and he's a young activist on
the far right of the republican party
he was very active in the republican
for the republicans in the recent senate
runoff race
and he has spoken openly of rebellion
this begins the rebellion and i will not
bow between before an illegitimate
government
not now not tomorrow not if they
imprison me
to help us get a better understanding of
what happened there we're joined by two
investigative reporters
who've been taking a close look at this
greg palace and zach
roberts and greg let me start with you
there wasn't supposed to even be a march
was there
right the the sponsors of the trump
rally on january 6 at the ellipse which
is the washington monument
absolutely said it's not in our permit
to march
they promised the washington metro
police we will not march
they told the white house there cannot
and will not be a mark
it's we're not set up to do it it's
dangerous
but everything changed when the
president called on his supporters
to march to the capitol we're going to
walk down and i'll be there with you
we're going to walk down we're going to
walk down
anyone you want but i think right here
we're going to walk down
to the capitol brian remember if you're
moving
tens of thousands of people across a
mile and a half of washington you have
to close the streets you have to have
police barricades
ambulances porta potties and of course
monitors
to make sure that people don't go out of
control but they did
at the same time another rally was
taking place at the capitol
led in part by a republican operative
named ali alexander
who later said he worked with three
republican congressmen to organize
the rally i was the person who came up
with the january sixth
idea with congressman gosar congressman
mo brooks and then congressman andy
biggs
we forced schemed up of putting maximum
pressure
on congress while they were voting so
that who we couldn't lobby
we could change the hearts and the minds
of republicans who were in that body
hearing our loud war from outside
alexander had earlier in georgia helped
lead protests against republicans
who failed to endorse president trump's
claims of voter fraud
and what was the reaction of the crowd
when he said that in georgia
oh they all started cheering they
started cheering usa usa
and enchanting you know uh you know
trump and
they all chanted america first america
first which is
you know become a rallying call beyond
make america great again
uh for these basically white
nationalists
uh that uh have started taking over the
republican party
and greg what you and zack have
documented really is the intersection
between uh
the far right and the republican party
well
there's not much distance between them
right yeah we i i was very shocked when
uh especially zach
uncovered because he he went under he
does go into cover for us
and went into their organization and uh
found out that ollie alexander
now this is after he made his statement
that we are going to
light this whole shit on fire so after
we had reported on his incendiary
remarks the georgia republican party
and then and the national republican
senate committee
headed by rick scott decided to use
ollie alexander after this threat
um to be the keynote at their meeting
for get out the vote
to win the georgia senate runoffs they
wanted to bring in
his 200 000 followers
as get out the vote troops for the
georgia runoff
even though they knew very well after
our reports and others
that he was constantly making violent
threats
also we have him on film yukking it up
with a nazi holding a giant swastika
flag
saying well let's talk about what we
have in common um which is quite
extraordinary so what do you think this
uh means in terms of the republican
party are they at the point now where
they are really
literally in lockstep with some of these
groups at least some of them
well i don't know again you know i
didn't hear back from the party i do
know it's the
it's the top leadership of the party in
georgia and in their senate campaign
which is rick scott's outfit
that decided to hook up with ollie
alexander you know
clearly what's attractive to them is
that his
massive hundreds of thousands of
followers that you know that
and they thought that they could
activate them to win the georgia runoff
i mean one of the problems we have
is this kind of playing ftse with the
alt-right that you have among some
elements of the republican party it's
not the entire republican party but
there were some congress members who are
very close to ollie alexander
and obviously alex jones zach every
american has the right to vote but not
the right to riot
do you think there's going to be more
violence in the months to come
under a biden administration i have uh
unfortunately almost no doubt um i was
the only thing i was surprised of
on january 6 is that it didn't happen
before then
everyone at this point comes prepared
for battle
to protest it's no longer just these
peaceful marches that we have
it is it is it is battle greg palace let
me ask you the same question do you
anticipate
more trouble more violence in the coming
months
yeah absolutely as zach was saying
you have people coming to demonstrations
aren't uh this is
this is new business they're coming to
demonstrations armed
i'm very concerned that the police for
example i've worked with law enforcement
it was a murder scene a crime scene the
capital a a cop had his head crushed by
a fire extinguisher why weren't people
as they walked out
um arrested had their phones confiscated
which has those selfies because
certainly
someone took pictures of the people that
that killed that cop
why weren't those phones confiscated and
then they were allowed to literally
leave a murder crime scene which is
astonishing
and so what that is is a signal to these
groups
if you're going to cause mayhem you may
have some help from the people who are
supposed to stop the mayhem
very troubling greg palast zach roberts
thank you both for joining us this
evening
fascinating insight and we'll get back
to you as the story continues to develop
thank you you're welcome brian
elliot alexander did not respond to our
request for a comment
he's told others despite what we saw on
tape that he's never had any role in
inciting violence
he has not been charged with any crime
in connection with the january 6th
insurrection coming up next a family
tragedy
and a showdown in court father against
son
over the murder of a mother you're
watching brian ross investigates
on the law and crime trial network
this week the iowa supreme court will
heal arguments in a case involving an
iowa farmer
jason carter accused by his father bill
carter of
murdering his mother shirley carter
jason carter was found not guilty of
murder charges in a criminal trial
but he was found guilty of that same
charge in a civil trial
in a case brought by his father bill
carter and ordered to pay
10 million dollars to bill carter
this week lawyers for jason carter will
argue before the court that he deserves
to have that verdict either overturned
or that he should receive a new trial
earlier i talked with jason carter
and his wife shelly about what they
hoped would happen
jason and shelly thank you very much for
being here what are your expectations
and hopes from this
supreme court hearing well
we're hoping that they'll either they'll
either throw it out
or at least overturn the the ruling
uh for the civil and give us a new trial
um you know our main hopes are just to
have it thrown out all together but
at the least get a new trial not guilty
um is that your verdict ladies and
gentlemen you were found not guilty in
the criminal trial
but still the civil trial verdict is
hanging over you what's it been like to
live with that
shelly and jason you can answer both i
don't know it's just
it's just like a monkey that's always on
your back and
um you know it's
it's just so wrong and so heartbreaking
you know it's it's really important that
our children
see how we've never given up uh and we
will never give up
i'll uh i'll fight this to the bitter
end
um there's no doubt about that there
until this is overturned or something's
done different
just have to keep on putting up a huge
fight carter's appeal will be argued by
allison kanye
making the case that there is new
evidence that came out during
carter's criminal trial about other
possible suspects
brian there are six different bases for
this appeal but there's one that we're
focusing on in particular and that is
the fact that the civil jury did not
have access to the same evidence that
the criminal jury had access to
after the civil trial concluded in
december of 2017
jason was charged with homicide and at
that point we began to receive
discovery from the state which showed us
that there were a number of other viable
suspects
with multiple multiple reports that
corroborated each other that had not
been adequately investigated by law
enforcement
that formed the basis of a lot of our
testimony and evidence offered in the
criminal trial
the civil jury did not have that same
opportunity we think it is only fair
and just that jason be given an
opportunity to present all of the
evidence
to this civil jury and then have them
make a decision did jason have to go on
trial again
is that more than you think he can bear
you know jason is extremely tough he's
been through more than
anyone i know in six years and i think
he will do whatever it takes
to continue to work towards clearing his
name obviously
he's been acquitted that's the most
important part but i don't worry about
jason getting tired
he was accused of murdering his mother
that's one of the most horrific things
you could ever possibly be accused of
and of course he wants to fight until
the better end to prove his innocence
whether it's in a civil courtroom
or a criminal courtroom so this civil
trial verdict still
hangs over his head in a way absolutely
it's a 10 million dollar civil judgment
bill carter has shown that he intends to
try and collect it if you can
how could that not hang over somebody's
head
has there been any attempt to sort of
settle this out of court
no i don't think either party would
agree to any kind of settlement jason
would certainly never agree to anything
that required him to admit that he
murdered shirley because he didn't
and bill carter seems convinced that
jason was responsible
even despite the quick acquittal that we
achieved in the criminal court
i don't think um settlement is a
possibility for either of these parties
jason have you talked with your father
at all since you were found not guilty
um no uh i haven't
i you know i've seen him in passing that
we farm right down the road from each
other
so it's kind of hard not to see each
other um
you know just driving by in the vehicle
or
tractor combine whatever have you uh
it's inevitable we see each other in
passing
but uh um it's funny because
one day he'll wave and and the next uh
you know you get a cold shoulder
but it goes both ways jason he told
us that he has tried to commit suicide
at least four separate times
i um i heard i heard that he has tried
seven or eight times to commit suicide
and uh yeah
um i i don't understand that
i mean i it's just uh
you know it's terrible you know brian
um you know i was with the family for 25
years before this happened
and it surely was
like my mom and billy was like my dad
that is not the man and you know
the man we know had more strength
and honor and
dignity that is not the man we know
and but that's the man he's become
and just it's sad after you were found
now guilty was there any new effort to
find
who was in fact guilty since you were
cleared by the jury
we've asked the local uh prosecutor
and law enforcement to look into
the people you know that
should be held responsible for this are
the people that we believe
uh are responsible
and we were told that nothing
was would ever happen no one was going
to look into anything
so well they've made public statements
both law enforcement and the prosecutor
have made public statements that it's a
cold case
um and that it's closed but
we know it's anything but should be
anything but closed
and we want to fight for the people that
have done this to be held responsible
and we want someone to truly investigate
you know everything that was never
investigated
and those people still walk out there
today
and let me tell you that that is deeply
sickening
it's pretty scary actually and it's
scary i don't know
i don't i don't know what could be done
or what can happen
you know it you know we know it's old
you know we know it's
cold but you know what we need someone
to do their job
for surely so you really want a chance
for another trial
absolutely i'm all for it let's go back
and really show people how things
were uh show them the true facts
not the smoke and mirrors that came in
the civil suit
so yep and then
i'm gung-ho i'm ready
all right thank you both very very much
for coming in and talking with us
thank you thank you brian
up next we'll hear from the other side
from bill carter jason carter's father
you're watching brian ross investigates
on the long crime
trial network
we continue now with our report on the
family tragedy involving the carter
family of iowa and we're joined by mark
weinhardt who's the lawyer for bill
carter mr weinhardt thank you for being
here you'll argue before the court this
week
about the case whether it should be
overturned or there should be a new
trial
why do you think he should not get a new
trial
well brian uh i'm going to be arguing to
the supreme court in 48 hours
and i don't think it's appropriate for
me to preview my
argument to the justices uh publicly i
will say
that we have every confidence that the
judge who conducted the civil trial in
december of 2017
did it right she made the right
decisions about what evidence did and
did come
into the case uh the jury heard that
evidence they made a decision very
quickly in just two hours
uh determined that jason was liable for
killing his mother
uh we think that that was the right
decision and
uh on thursday afternoon we're going to
defend that decision in the iowa supreme
court
as you know the argument is that there's
new information about other possible
suspects who were never
according to jason carter's lawyers
fully investigated
does bill carter think still that his
son
killed shirley carter bill is
firmly convinced that jason killed
shirley
which has to be one of the most shocking
and troubling things that a father could
ever conclude
about his own offspring and yet bill
came to that conclusion based on the
evidence
he is firm in that conclusion the
so-called
new evidence is something that jason had
an
opportunity to present to the judge who
heard
the civil trial he spent three days we
had a second trial effectively
for three days where he was able to
present all of that evidence to that
judge
that judge decided two things first she
decided that that evidence which was
rumors hearsay innuendo from people in
jail trying to make
deals because of their own criminal
circumstances uh she decided that that
evidence
was not admissible that even if there
were a new trial the jury wouldn't
be allowed to hear it because under the
rules of evidence it simply did not come
into the case
second she decided that that evidence
simply did not square
with the uncontested facts of the case
that just did not match the physical
facts
of how it was that shirley was murdered
and so she determined that that evidence
did not warrant a new trial and that's
what we're going to be defending in two
days is the judge's decision
about how that alleged evidence does not
in fact change the case at all
mr weinhardt a question for you from
rhonda schwartz rhonda
it's such a family tragedy how is your
client bill carter who's in his 80s
holding up through all this
you know um bill is a man of routine
and he's a man of the earth he has been
farming
the same plot of land for more than 50
years and he's grown that farm he's a
scrimper and a saver
uh and uh the rhythm
of the planting season and
the rhythm of life in the farm economy
that's what keeps him going it's what
keeps him uh putting one foot in front
of the other
every day um were he to retire i don't
know what would happen to him but as
long as he's got the farm and as long as
he's got that life
uh in the very home where he and surely
spent all those decades
on the land that the two of them work
together as long as he's got that
uh he gets by sadder
wiser but he gets by
all right mark weinhardt thank you so
much we look forward to
watching your arguments before the iowa
supreme court and continue to report on
the story
a program reminder a story about the
carter case
will appear on a e thursday night at 10
as part of the lawn
crime production series killer cases i'm
brian ross thank you for joining us
and thanks to everyone at the law and
crime team who so ably get us
on the air and off the air without a
hitch
[Music]
so